I'm Mike selling kerr i'm a puzzle maker
so I work for loan shark games the May
issue of wired is about enigmas
mysteries puzzles and games and so we
got the opportunity to permeate the
entire magazine with the kinds of
puzzles that would make us interested so
we really wanted to make this issue
about puzzles that were wired puzzles
not just random puzzles that you'll find
imagine the things that really made
sense to the wired reader so for example
we have a word search nice little word
search except it's old computer models
but we don't tell you the names of the
computer models we just give you the
memory sizes we figure that should be
enough for a liar we decided to do an
acid oka because people like the Sudoku
but instead of doing a normal number
sodoku we did an LED sydow building so
instead of seeing the whole number what
you see is a little flash of LED which
could be part of a six it could be part
of a nine and you have to figure out it
on your own we got some of our favorite
people to help us out with this issue we
got a very wide range of puzzle makers
so I got Will Shortz and we wanted to
get one that felt like it was a word
puzzle but not just your average word
puzzle so we made it into a DNA code on
matching puzzle we brought in martin
gardner who is America's oldest living
puzzle maker gardener and basically
invented the math puzzle and so we we
decided to jump off on that and
on a puzzle called the toothpick puzzle
we got way while wang x of google he's
done a great little television puzzle
highlighting the fact that we're about
to make this massive transition to
digital television but we found out that
JJ Abrams was going to be involved in
this issue we really embraced the notion
of making this like in SS Adams catalog
where everywhere you turn in the
magazine there was something interesting
to look at there's no dead space
anywhere in this issue if you're just
flipping through the magazine you're
going to see all sorts of things that
you might be intrigued by but if you sit
down with this for a while you're going
to find that it comes back at you in
lots of ways you hadn't even noticed we
tried to go for things that were not
only interesting and I think that's sort
of what why are people want in their
magazine is something that that rewards
them for paying attention to what's
going on around
you